So, how do we do this?
Now, this will relate back to
the concepts we had looked at
when we looked at the frequency
domain of an image.
That is,
how do we actually start representing
things at a different frequency
spectrum and of course,
we played around with
things like the pyramid.
So, to achieve this,
basically we would have to find in
the scale and the pyramids of images,
the most amount of information
in both space and in scale.
Space in this case would
be the image itself.
Scale is, again,
the pyramid levels for example.
Being able to find information
at different frequency spectrum
differently.
So one of the more important methods
that's actually widely used is,
as I said, SIFT,
Scale Invariant Feature Transform.
For this process,
what is suggested is that basically use
the pyramid to find the maximum values.
Again, we use this kind of stuff
to do things like edge detection.
And in this case, then eliminate
the edges and pick only the corners.
So, run the same process that
we've been doing before,
except that now find all edges
using different frequencies and
then eliminate the edges and
pick only the corners.
So again, the same concept that we've
been doing for corner detection, but
except we do it at multiple scales.
We find edges at multiple scales.
And then we basically kind of say,
look here.
Which one of them are corners at
each and every one of the scales?
So in essence, what happens now
is that basically each point
is compared to its eight neighbors,
shown here.
So each point is compared
to its eight neighbors.
And then we can of course
also scale it up and down.
And in this case, each point is also
compared to its nine neighbors above and
below in scale.
So eight local neighbors at this point,
and
then above, nine points,
below, nine points.
And these are of course different
scales which could be computed using,
again, things like pyramids and
stuff like that we've looked at.